vt has been covering the Met Gala longer
than any other show but we have never
seen anything like this year's event
amazing here's the thing Nancy the stars
came to play and Kelty night was there
and Kelty I know this is you at your
happiest moment isn't it Kevin you know
me and you know how much I freaked out
over these things and I'm still freaking
out did I sleep in my gown last night
well there is a very good possibility
that happened the fashion was
mind-blowing and everyone got into the
holy spirit of the event starting with
our favorite goddess I'm always proud of
them all I was gonna wear this earlier
and it just didn't look like the Jiffy
Pop the Clooney's arrived together but
Amal stole the spotlight the Met Gala
co-hosts were a silver bodice satin
pants and a dramatic train with a
gorgeous floral print designer Richard
Quinn actually used a digital printer to
create the stained glass like a fact on
the foil skirt of a mall strain a mall
actually rocked for looks last night
first she left her hotel with George in
the afternoon wearing trousers then on
the red carpet she added that stunning
floral train she returned to her hotel
in a red sequined dress and then hit the
after-party without George in a
multicolored mini dress another divine
look Rihanna's Pope inspired outfit
[Music]
we've had a few fittings we've had in a
few colors they beated this by hand it
will be a sin not to wear it RiRi wore a
beaded skirt over a bustier dress and a
white bishops hat to match and listen to
this the papal ensemble took a
staggering 250 hours to sew and 500
hours to hand embroider the epic gown
was designed by John Galliano
but Rihanna's night didn't end there
just before 2:00 a.m. RiRi hit up and
down nightclub with five bodyguards in
this super casual sparkly pj look
designed by nina ricci another Met Gala
standout JLo in this blue bomb on gown
with a red and blue cross her man a rod
wore a custom suit also by Baba the
couple celebrated a red-carpet
anniversary guys made your debut here
one year ago how does it feel to be back
at the Met it's been an awesome year
lots happen I mean this is gorgeous
I couldn't believe when I first saw her
today James got engaged earlier on these
steps could there be a royal wedding in
the future for you guys royal wedding
JLo changed for the after-party slipping
into a shimmering mini dress with blue
and red beads
[Applause]
[Music]